he's Travis Meadows singer-songwriter
and I love this that it says Travis
Meadows is an orphan who turned into a
preacher a preacher turned into a
songwriter songwriter turned into a
drunk a drunk that is learning to be a
human being currently on tour in support
of his latest album first cigarette and
a new video that we premiered today
which is one of my favorite songs it's
uh underdogs responsible for writing
Kenny Chesney's new single better boat
which also can be found on Travis's
album it's great to finally meet you and
thank you for the great music oh thank
you for having me it's been great um
explain the video so when you're
watching the video there of underdogs
what are you thinking well I mean it's
kind of a hodgepodge you know I wanted
it to be as broad as it could possibly
be you know because I feel like it at
some point we've all felt like an
underdog or overlooked or you know
missed a job opportunity because we
weren't good-looking enough for you know
the main whatever it was and so we
wanted to be really broad so you see a
lot of people just kind of going through
the everyday grind of life trying to
trying to make something happen how
tough is I mentioned this that a lot of
musicians live the life therefore it's
easier to write the song the song comes
to you through life mm-hmm you live the
life Oh totally if I said you didn't
have to live that life and you had a
nice easy life and you didn't have these
songs like what would you what would you
take oh man you know Harlan Howard was
famous for saying that same thing is if
we could as if we could pick our life
that you know your before you before
you're born you look down and say you
know when the songwriters pick the
hardest life because that's where the
songs come from it depends on when you
ask me right now I'm feeling pretty good
I'd probably go through it right now
you know in the middle of it not so much
what was it like though like at your
lowest point it was horrible it was
absolutely horrible I mean you know in
recovery groups they talk about you know
everybody has a bottom and in mind the
floor just kept coming out of it and I
followed it alone I couldn't find the
bottom you know as hard as I was trying
and but that last trip to jail just kind
of solidified the deal for me I keep I
keep notes in my phone for
for song ideas right and and I can I
call it my bag of tricks and sometimes
I'll be scolding I'll go through years
of it and there'll be countless times
which says remember how this feels and I
don't remember what I was going through
but apparently I was like you know it's
time for a change dozens of those
remember how this feels and I should
have put a note like you know as you're
sitting your butt in jail or what are
you several surprised you're still alive
I'm yeah yeah the last time I checked
myself into rehab they I've actually
become friends with the guy that checked
me in and the fourth time that are
called and asked for help he said hey
Travis Meadows wants to check in and he
goes he's still alive true story yeah
but when we had you on when we first
introduced to you you were telling us
the titles of country songs you hadn't
even written yet when you said my
ex-girlfriend died and I don't know how
to feel right that's a country song Oh
totally yeah I woke up in jail naked but
this is your life that you're describing
here but it sounds like those are
country songs yeah it's almost like a
bad joke in it yeah but when it comes to
writing do they just come quickly or do
well there's there's a they all come
differently sometimes I'm just strumming
the guitar and it'll just kind of start
flowing out sometimes I'll get an idea
and up and I have to marinate just kind
of chew on it sometimes for weeks like
the song sideways on the new record that
that happens so fast that I thought
there's no way it could be a good song
because it happened in about 30 minutes
that never happens better both the one
that Kenny just recorded that I remember
distinctly riding with Liz roads and
that was an eight-hour day with a couple
of sandwiches in between and just about
ready to give up you know we're just
working on that last line so and I have
some that I've literally worked for for
months on a couple that were years just
taking a minute to kind of get them out
when do you know a song is done
completely yeah it's kind of my heart
just tells me you know well I'll write
it and then I kind of have to walk away
from it and and then come back to it
because you you get so in the middle of
it while you're writing it you just kind
of after a while you you don't know if
it's any good or not you know I want you
to we're talking to Travis meadows
the song is underdogs
the album is called cigarette first
cigarette Pauly do you want to give
Travis the country titles for our lives
oh yeah these were each like description
of what our country songs we a blind
bastard five weeks in Morgantown The
Ballad of Jenny Bochy the girl Dan lost
and then Todd Fritz back there it's a
flatbed full of hand lotion and that's
self-explanatory Wow yeah those are
great
what was that said what was the second
one five weeks in Morgantown
those are good titles now you could
write something five weeks in Morgantown
I could totally right right yeah I could
do that I mean you might have spent a
year there or it might you might have
spent a week and it felt like five weeks
in Morgan a lot of times when I'm
writing with another artist you know
we'll just have a long discussion and I
just try to get inside of their head
what was going on in Morgantown would be
the first question what was happening
why is it what it made such an
impression and just try to get inside
you know do you name a song have you
ever had a title and then written a song
Oh a lot yeah that's actually these days
especially because I've written you know
I've written every song I know to write
three or four times you know just keep
writing until I get them right and and
at this point in my career a good title
is almost impossible it's gold so so
well you know I'll write down our title
and kind of hang on to it and yeah I I
keep trying to get somebody to write a
song I have the title that you can't
spell blame without me that's it's good
but I I mean you got to write it now
okay can you do that yeah you can't
spell blame without me yeah and it'll be
Travis meadows featuring Dan Patrick
yeah yeah we can do that all right good
I mean I would never you know I would
never take your title and then you know
you can have it absolutely like it's my
gift to you or thank you for what you've
given to me I give that to you that's
awesome and I I think you can obviously
hear the voice and you know that I'm a
George Jones type yeah yeah yeah I can
hear it yeah yeah I can hear that yeah
like a little Johnny Cash yeah no doubt
yeah hello I'm Dan Pat hello I'm Johnny
Cash
can you do Ring of Fire uh no I don't
think I can get that low you know what's
funny to admit in front all these people
I have the hardest time remembering
lyrics I may or may not have done a few
things that were more fun than the law
allowed in my brain I mean uh I've got I
got my phone sitting here with lyrics
just in case I need him I'm not even
kidding your pharmacy I got always have
a cheat sheet but you know a lot of the
big guys do that and they don't tell you
and they disguise it a monitor yeah
that's a little inside baseball they had
that Montand it looks like a monitor but
they got the cheat sheet once I saw that
I'm like when I'm not alone out here do
you cover other artists I do not I you
know I try to I try to keep myself busy
enough that I don't know what anybody
else is doing honestly and it's working
but who did you follow like you all of a
sudden you decide you're gonna be a
country okay I started off on drums I
had a guy that lived two doors down for
me he was a left-handed drummer and I'm
left-handed and I would go down there
and and he would go eat dinner and he
had a little closet set up and he and
the first song that I learned to play
was Detroit Rock City yes yeah and then
the second one it was a jailbreak by
Thin Lizzy
which one of people don't even remember
so anyway I got started on the drums and
anything allowed in rock and roll I
would pay attention to you know and then
riding around my grandparents raised me
riding around in that old Cadillac you
know they would put on country so I
would listen to you know George Jones
and Johnny Cash and Conway Twitty and
all of those guys and then I moved to
Gatlinburg Tennessee when I was 21 and I
was gonna I was gonna play bluegrass and
smoke weed and I'm not in that order not
necessarily in that order and and then I
found out how hard bluegrass was to play
and I opted out for just smoking weed
but while I was there I had just picked
up a guitar and while I was there I went
into this little place juggies deli and
they were serving sandwiches and there
was a couple of guys and they're playing
guitar and it was the first time you
know I lost a lot of hearing like 40% of
my hearing point up with chemotherapy
when I was a kid so I really have a hard
time hearing words and for the first
time I heard guys singing like Neil yon
just the guitar and the lyrics and
Springsteen and
Ellen camp and all those guys that uh
that I grew to love because of that and
listening to the lyric and so I asked
the lady could I sit in for the lunch
crowd
I knew three songs she said sure because
I'm seeing you don't see in the tip jar
there and I'm thinking good there's got
to be $20 that's a big day so I asked if
she said yes so I played the three songs
and and then I said okay I got to take a
break and that those guys left and a new
crowd came in to get a sandwich and then
I played the same three songs and the
next day I knew four or five and good
for you yeah
hearts I leave behind is is just
beautiful that's actually a record a
couple of times by a couple of guys over
in Australia and then of course I can't
remember the name but but that's one of
the few that actually got it recorded oh
it's beautifully written it really is
and that's what I told people that I
listen to what you're saying and then
how you're saying it in that order
Opry City stage in Times Square tomorrow
night and then stone pony in Asbury Park
New Jersey on November 2nd maybe
Springsteen comes by I pray for jungling
that's probably how would you do if
Springsteen walked in I would I would
probably melt a little bit that's one of
the few guys that I would probably be a
little star sir you haven't been around
Springsteen Paulie bring in Bruce
Springsteen yeah who's the country
singer if he walked in you would know
yep totally more Merle Haggard I had
tickets to his show I you know my
grandparents on the concessions at the
Coliseum in Jackson Mississippi so
everybody that came through us all for
free including Elvis twice I saw
everybody never saw him roll Haggard I
had tickets how old were you when you
saw Elvis oh good lord
nine eight nine you know my grandfather
used to actually work with Colonel Tom
and the carnival I can't I don't think I
can say what they they did but would say
they used to shovel elephant poop
together that's another story they said
and and so we needed somebody to to come
and do some attribute shows because
Mississippi had gotten rocked by some
tornadoes and my granddad said I think I
could probably get Elvis and they
laughed at him you don't laugh at my
grandma and so a couple weeks go by and
he calls him he says hey you suckers
come in I got
no meeting for you colonel Tom and Elvis
came walking in everything silence in
the room a real awkward moment cuz my
granddad pulled it off
and he did two shows and if you know
anything about they didn't do nothing
for free yeah donated every dime to
Mississippi those two shirts awesome
yeah you're from Jackson Mississippi
Walter Payton is from Jackson
Mississippi the running back at former
rush cagonu I'm trying to actually
remember the name but I'm trying to act
like I'm knowledgeable no I remember
that's a guy that could jump yeah he
jump over the yeah pile there yeah the
album is a first cigarette better bode
wrote for Kenny Chesney first cigarette
is the latest album and he's written
songs for Hank Williams jr. Eric Church
Dierks Bentley quite a few guys but the
latest album featuring underdogs which
is one of my favorite songs for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]